est-ce que tu aimerais vivre avec un
homme tout le temps et et voir peut-être
avoir des enfants tu y as pensé déjà non
non je su pas droit parce que ma mère va
VO
porteclé de
grenouille là c'est cludie qui me refer
là c'est là c'est poster Valérie 23 ans
ah c'est une femme qui vit dans une
chambre d'enfants tout simplement parce
que CEN est encore un
âge mental 7 ans
trisomique c'est cassette de TR petits
crochons ça
con chaque weekend elle retrouve ses
parents après avoir passé une semaine
dans un centre spécialisé ce jourl sa
mère aborde un sujet délicat encore
tabou en France il s'appelle comment ton
copain
Fabrice je voulais je voulais savoir
donc il te il te caresse sur les seins
sur le ventre et ben en bas aussi et en
bas sur ton petit zizi aussi ah pourquoi
ah oui que ce soit avec Fabrice ou avec
un autre tu tu vas en rencontrer
d'autres he est-ce que tu aimerais vivre
avec un homme tout le temps et et voir
peut-être avoir des enfants tu y as
pensé déjà non non je suis pas droit
parce que ma mère vaut
pas papa il veut
pas va pas elle est suivie dans son dans
son centre où elle a donc des des
infirmières qui tous les jours lui
donnent sa pilule parce qu'elle a une
pilule qui tous les jours donc là il y a
un suivi mais on sait très très bien que
si elle n'est pas il y a pas quelqu'un
qui lui donne son médicament tous les
jours et bien elle ne le fera pas
forcément bonjour madame bonjour
monsieur si vous voulez
venir vous souhaitez venir avec votre
fille oui très bien rentrez bonjour
bonjour bonjour madame bonjour monsieur
pour régler le problème de contraception
de Valérie rendez-vous est pris chez un
gynécologue de Versailles j'ai pas droit
c'est ce qu'on recherche c'est de savoir
quelle est la meilleure solution qui
puisse proposer à Valérie
euh à partir du moment où comme tout
être humain considérons qu'elle a le
droit à une sexualité certains parents
sur les conseils des établissements
optent pour une piqûure trimestrielle un
défaut elle favorise l'obésité autre
solution le stérilet la tolérance du
stérilet n'est pas très bonne je dis pas
qu'on ne puisse pas en mettre mais on a
souvent des réactions douloureuses et
des saignements très fréquents mais
avant d'aller plus loin le médecin
conseille à Valérie de
sortir est-ce que vous tes déjà pensé
stériliser
Valérie c'est une chose qu'on qu'on
auquel on a déjà réfléchi à mon avis la
stérilisation tubère est la meilleure
solution car c'est elle qui amène le
moins d'effet secondair elle n'en amène
pratiquement jamais est-ce qu'elle peut
se faire à l'occasion d'une une autre
opération par exemple d'une crise
d'apanicite bien sûr à l'occasion de
n'importe quelle ouverture de la cavité
abdominale ou d'une céoscopie faite pour
une autre intervention on peut
naturellement faire une section des
trompes à ce moment-là est-ce que vous
êtes plus rassuré vis-à-vis de la
stérilisation plus près de franchir le
pas ou plus près de franchir le pas
certainement et vous je confirme tout à
fait tout à fait et je souhaiterais
c'était dommage je souhaiterais presque
qui a une autre opération pour être
enfin tranquille et qu'il ait cette
stérilisation réalisée tôt ou tard
Valérie devrait être stérilisé car ses
parents redoutent avant tout un
avortement seul petit problème c'est
illégal en France et aucune assurance ne
couvre le médecin pendant l'acte et les
deux mamans nous ont rejoint Janine
chanteur et André Chapu Janine chanteur
vous avez une fille oui qui est
handicapée légère elle lit très mal elle
n'écrit pratiquement pas elle ne peut
pas aconter elle n'a pas d'autonomie
est-ce que vous avez songé un
jour à cette possibilité la
stérilisation je n'ai jamais voulu
qu'elle soit stérilisée jamais je ne me
suis jamais reconnu le droit et mon mari
pas davantage de faire un pareil acte
sur notre
enfant moi je défend les droits de
l'homme et je crois que les personnes
handicapées ont des droits elles aussi
est-ce que parfois certaines personnes
voulent recommander oui bien sûr bien
sûr
des médecins des associations des
personnes dans les
associations mais toute contraception
réversible me paraît parfaitement
acceptable mais une contraception
définitive jamais et je me suis rendu
compte
en fréquentant beaucoup les jeunes
handicapés que la façon
dont nous les voyons dont nous les
pensons
influ beaucoup sur eux
influ sur leur progrès et influ sur leur
bonheur d'être au monde si vous vivez
votre enfant tel que il ne progressera
jamais et que s'il met un enfant au
monde c'est une catastrophe et bien je
crois que vous le cond
comment
réagissez-vous en écoutant le témoignage
de Josette en écoutant le témoignage de
Marcelle et
bien je suis
navrée je suis désespéré pour elle et je
me dis que moi j'ai eu la chance d'avoir
C enfants même si j'en ai perdu un même
si j'en ai une handicapé et qu'elle avec
l'enfance qu'elle avait eu n'aura jamais
d'enfant alors qu'elle pouvait en avoir
un alors bien sûr moi je ne juge
personne parce que le problème est grave
tous les parents ne sont pas prêts à
accepter l'enfant de leur enfant
handicapé et de toute façon je dirais
que si ma fille avait eu un enfant je ne
veux pas dire nous l'aurions élevé parce
que nous ne luaurions pas volé mais nous
l'aurions aidé après tout nousons nous
aidons bien nos autres enfants
évidemment beaucoup moins ils n'en ont
pas besoin
mais vous savez quand on a un
enfant on a décidé de donner quelque
chose de sa vie et on ne sait pas
jusqu'à quel point il faudra donner
quelque chose et on n'est pas malheureux
pour autant André chap vous avez vous
deux enfants handicapésou tout à fait et
vous n'avez pas la même réaction
absolument pas Madame chanteur je pense
d'ailleurs que toutes les ré les
réactions sont respectables le handicap
est d'une variété absolue la seule chose
qui réunissent l'ensemble des des
handicapés est souvent la difficulté de
comprendre la gestion du quotidien pour
eux-mêmes nous les protégeons en
général sur le plan juridique en les
mettant sous tutelle je ne vois pas
pourquoi nous ne les protégerions pas
pour vivre une vie avec les autres mais
légèrement différente pour leur
épanouissement leur autonomie mais ne
pas leur donner de responsabilité qu'il
ne pourrai assumer ça veut dire que vous
comptez faire procéder à une
stérilisation je pense que c'est le
moyen de contraception non hypocrite qui
met les jeunes à l'abri de tous les
accidents préjudiciable à leur équilibre
quel âge ont vos enfants ma fille est
née à 34 ans ma seconde fille fille à 27
ans je pense que ma seconde fille est
totalement capable d'accepter et de
comprendre je ne suis pas du tout sûre
que je puisse l'expliquer et le faire
comprendre à ma fille aînée alors si
votre seconde fille vous vous dit non et
refuse nous avons déjà abordé ce
problème ensemble et elle m'a dit de
son tout à fait
naturellement que elle n'avent pas envie
d'enfant que son désir était de vivre
avec un ami mais qu'elle n'était pas
capable d'assumer un enfant elle a 27
ans je pense que son âge mental n'est
pas
celui-là et que elle peut évoluer mais
je ne pense pas assurer son bonheur et
l'équilibre d'un enfant qui viendrait à
naître dans des conditions pareilles
est-ce que vous vous dites pas ce
problème au fond est infiniment complexe
bien sûr bien sûr il est d'une extrême
complexité il est dommage de le de le
réduire ire et de de de l'analyser de
façon si partielle et partiale je dirais
de temps euh je ne suis pas euh je je ne
suis pas parent d'enfant handicapé je je
ne je je suis chercheur si vous voulez
donc moi je n'ai pas le droit de juger
telle ou telle décision par contre ce
que je peux dire et ce que je souhaite
dire c'est quand vous dites madame que
vous croyez avoir épargné à votre fille
par exemple beaucoup de de problèmes
voyez bon avez-vous pensé à la
contamination par sida ce que je veux
dire c'est que
aujourd'hui non non ce n'est pas un
autre problème madame le le le problème
de la stérilisation des personnes
handicapé aujourd'hui évacue
complètement vous le savez bien le
problème de la prévention des des
maladies sexuellement transmissibles
évacu le problème de de la de
l'éducation sexuelle c'est la première
chose que je souhaiterais dire la
deuxième chose que je souhaiterais dire
c'est pourquoi ce sont toujours des
femmes qui sont stérilisées je vous
propose d'écouter des handicapés
confrontés évidemment à ce problème et
très attentif à tout ce qui se dit
autour d'eux grâce à ce reportage de
Frédéric Rota et de Vincent
bouffartig c'est un groupe de 10
personnes que chacun leur tour ils font
manger ils font le ménage la cuisine
toutes les tâches qu' a dans la vie
collective les courses c'est eux qui
font Sébastien est témoin au cotidien de
la vie affective de ce que l'on appelle
ici les résidents comme dans toute
collectivité la mixité ne se V passe en
petit
problème des fois ils savent pas bien où
s'arrêter quoi donc il arrive que des
gestes un peu déplacés parfois quoi mais
génér com comment
réagissez discute avec eux que ça se
passe le mieux possible
qu Olivier a 25 ans et vient juste
d'emménager dans ce foyer il sait que le
règlement intérieur est strict aucun
acte sexuel n'est possible
icious visiter sa chambre Olivier se
livre un peu je suis un peutiré par elle
c'est toutes les filles me draguent et
après il me laisse tombero pour eux je
suis plus le plus beau garçon
d'ci du foyer quoi et ça pose quel genre
de problème ça ça rend ça rend les
filles
jalouses à mon boulot plus ici ah bon
j'ai une copine à mon boulot plus une
ici mais elle ve pas me le
dire
voilà tu tu es amoureuse d'une fille ici
ouais mais elle sait
pas c'est interdit de de de draguer ici
en draguer non mais de de faire faire
les choses qu'on a pas faire sintaller
ici parce qu'il y a du monde et parce
que ça pourrait gêner d'autres personnes
vivant là un couple qui se forme ici on
va demander s'il y a des relations
sexuelles qu'il puisse les vivre dans un
autre qu'est-ce que vous fait c'est donc
à l'hôtel ou chez les familles que
l'acte sexuel se pratique le rôle des
éducateurs se porte alors principalement
sur la prévention des grossesse sur
l'information en matière de
contraception il y a des résidentes qui
comprennent très bien qui sont qui
arrivent ici qui sont complètement
autonome qui prennent déjà des moyens de
contraception il y en a d'autres c'est
nous qui les orientons et qui ont
beaucoup plus de difficultés à
comprendre les cycles qui sont pas du
tout au courant de de comment fonctionne
leur corps quoi donc bon on essaie de
leur expliquer tout
en 14 ans on a eu un couple qui a eu un
enfant et puis il y a eu à à décider
autour de trois avortement donc bien que
des hommes et des femmes vivent ensemble
c'est pas vraiment quelque chose de
difficile à gérer parce qu'en fait la la
vie au quotidien n'est pas centré sur ce
qui touche à la sexualité c'est centré
sur la vie en
général ici il y a la
cuisine l'association d'omus donne la
possibilité à ceux qui le veulent de
vivre en couple relativement autonome
cyil et Karine sont visités chaque
semaine par des
éducateurs ça fait combien de temps que
que vous habitez ensemble ça va faire 6
mois et 4 jours 4
jours j'imagine que ça doit être
agréable
ouais c'est agréable ouais puis ça doit
changer du foyer où vous étiez avant
ouais ça change du foyer où j'étais
avant vous avez envie d'avoir des
enfants vous y avez
pensé
ça vous ferait
plaisir ça
rien et vous les gens qui sont qui sont
autour de vous ils'en pensent
quoi du fait d'avoir des enfants ils
vous ils vous
disent ma mère me dit tu sais
euh il faut vraiment réfléchir
avant de faire faire un enfant et tout
ça il faut vraiment être bien bien bien
dans sa peau pour
avoir un enfant on a le droit de
rencontrer l' la la la femme la femme de
sa vie pour pouvoir après euh des
enfants plus tard avoir des
enfants plus tard on est né pour progrès
de toute
manière l'homme et la femme sont né pour
pour pour procréer pour faire des
enfants les élever les aimer on a
beaucoup parlé de de médecins qui ont
fait des stérilisations sur des femmes
notamment qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
ça vous ben moi je trouve
que bah ça me choque un petit peu ouais
mais benah je voudrais pas que que ça
nous
arrive qui sera le plus fort le désir
d'enfant ou la sagesse sugéré par
l'entourage pour l'instant Karine comme
des milliers de jeunes filles prend la
[Musique]
pilule